well the footage is significantly worse
than the george floyd video
to my mind though it has attracted
barely a fraction of the attention and
the outrage
mohammed anwar was a 66 year old
pakistani immigrant in dc he was killed
this past tuesday
while delivering food for uber eats two
black teenage girls ages 13 and 15
attacked anwar with a taser while
carjacking him as he tried desperately
to reclaim his property
which he needed you know he needed his
car to do his job and provide for his
family
the girl sped away with anwar partially
hanging out of the vehicle
they flipped the car in the escape
attempt a few blocks down sending anwar
careening several feet away and he died
cell phone video shows the victim
splayed out on the ground
mangled and bleeding while national
guardsmen who
of course are in the city as you've
heard pull the murderers out of the
wreck
and the primary concern for both of
those girls is that their phones may
have been damaged they're they're
running around
screaming about their phones while this
man is dead
nobody at the scene on the video anyway
to include the guardsmen
show any apparent concern for the dead
man on the sidewalk
this crime is part of a growing trend in
dc over the weekend
two 13-year-old boys were arrested for
multiple
armed carjackings in the city a few days
before that
and a few days after anwar's death a
different pair of teenage boys 13 and 14
this time
were also arrested and charged for an
armed carjacking for those keeping track
at home
that makes what six kids all under the
age of 16
arrested for violent carjackings in the
same city in the same week
the mayor of dc fortunately has the
situation under control on sunday she
tweeted out a psa video
recommending strategies quote to reduce
the risk of your vehicle becoming a
target
with an accompanying protect your auto
hashtag
now this of course is no different than
a mayor responding to a string of rapes
in the city by putting out a video
recommending that women wear longer
skirts now feminists are quick to remind
us that
rape is the result not of provocative
fashion choices by the victims but of
evil actions by the rapist himself
in the case of anwar's death the tragedy
was caused not by his failure to protect
his auto which he tried to protect it
but by the behavior of two teenage girls
who have managed to become murderous
psychopaths before either of them is old
enough to
you know buy a ticket to a rated r movie
the question we're afraid to ask but
must ask
is how do kids turn into this how do
they turn into monsters
like this take a couple steps further
back
widen the lens and it's clear that the
trend extends beyond a carjacking
epidemic in dc
you know you could draw a line that
connects this incident
to for example the the equally tragic
case of e lee
in milwaukee a few months ago miss lee
an asian woman
was lounging alone in a local park when
a group of black teens happened across
her
and they decided to um physically and
sexually assault her
apparently just for fun before dragging
her to a nearby pond
and leaving her for dead one of the
teens charged in her murder comer lewis
age 17 explained that he didn't really
care if she lived or died because quote
because quote he didn't know her
personally
now a few weeks ago in rochester two
black teens aged 14 and 16 broke into 53
year old stephen amenhiser's house
doused him in some kind of lighter fluid
might have been gasoline
and set him on fire he died a few days
later in the hospital
disfigured and in agony with burns over
70
of his body within a few days of that
crime a white
middle-aged girl in a virginia suburb
was gunned down by a black teen lucia
bremer
13 years old was walking through the
neighborhood with a friend at 4
30 in the afternoon in the suburbs when
she was approached by the gunman and
fatally shot
no motive has yet been given we're told
by the family by the way that
lucia was supposed to help with the
neighborhood easter egg hunt
this weekend the racial dynamics of
these crimes
make them politically inconvenient for
the media which is why you haven't heard
very much about them
indeed the crimes defy all of the usual
talking points and standard explanations
there isn't even a potential gun control
angle on any of them except the last
one victim was burned to death another
tortured raped and beaten another killed
by
teen girls wielding a taser in a stolen
car
these crimes cannot be pinned on racism
at least not the brand of racism that
the media prefers to talk about and they
can't be used to push the kind of
policies the left favors
so our strategy then as a culture is to
look away
pretend it's not happening i really
think the image of the crowd
stepping around anwar's broken body and
not not even
looking at him is a tragic metaphor
because this is the strategy that our
whole society has adopted to these kinds
of things
still these kinds of things are
happening and
frequently young kids often not yet at
an age where they can obtain a learner's
permit
are committing unthinkable acts of
brutality against totally innocent
people
who pose no threat to them now whenever
there's a mass shooting of random
victims in a school or some other public
place
we generally will turn our attach
attention to it and we'll engage in
serious conversation and debate about
what can be done to stop the bloodshed
but these smaller scale acts of casual
sadism
are much more common and widespread
they happen literally every day in our
cities
many more people are killed many more
communities are terrorized
you know during trump's administration
his critics were fond of responding to
whatever he did or tweeted by saying
this isn't normal this isn't normal
well i wish the same could be said of a
13 year old murdering a man for his car
i wish i could say this isn't normal but
it is
it's normal the murder rate in most
major cities attest to that it is normal
but it shouldn't be now it's not
difficult to identify
some of the factors that have made these
kinds of things normal it can be assumed
without even checking we can assume
right now and i'm willing to say right
now
my guess without looking is that most
or all of the kids involved in the
crimes that i just listed have been
raised in homes without fathers
we we know that right off the bat
this is the case for the majority of
black children especially in the city
and it's increasingly the case for
children of all races as unwed
parenthood becomes
more and more common compounding the
problem many kids
spend their days marinating in the
nihilistic filth produced by
half-literate sociopaths like cardi b
the rapper lil nas x made waves this
past week when he released a music video
which shows him sliding down to hell
on a stripper pole and giving a lap
dance to satan
the video was accompanied by the release
of his new quote satan
shoes which feature a pentagram and
actual human blood
in the shoe lil nazex who cultivated a
large fan base of children with his
first hit
old country road or rather old old town
road i think it was called
which itself was vapid brain numbing
garbage and i said as much if you may
remember on this show when that song was
popular
anybody got a lot of children fans
because of that because of that dumb
awful song and now he's trying
desperately to shock us with a stick
that was
that well you know really wasn't even
all that shocking when marilyn manson
did it 25 years ago
now the only difference is that marilyn
manson never pretended to be an artist
for kids
uh this guy this dirt bag did
so he had a whole lot of kids
subscribing to his youtube channel
and then without warning he drops the
video of him giving a lap dance to satan
a bunch of nine-year-olds watch that
this weekend without their parents
knowing
still the content itself only fails to
shock us because we're so accustomed
to living in a culture where putrid
toxic sludge
is pumped out of hollywood and the music
industry and directly into our
children's minds
this is the situation that many millions
of kids find themselves in
they have no moral guidance at home
they consume immediate diet of non-stop
perversity and degeneracy they live
lives that are 90 percent online
conditioned to see other
humans as disembodied avatars on a
screen
there's no beauty in their lives no
truth no goodness no joy no love that's
a that's another prediction i can make
about all those kids
we talked about earlier how can we be
surprised
when they only when they turn into
killers and criminals
what else would they become what else
would you expect
it's only going to get worse from here
unless we set about to make
massive massive cultural changes
but to do that would require us to
confront the problem honestly
from the start that's the first step
and we don't have the courage to take it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content